Did you know that half of the Canary Islanders
born in the archipelago do not have Spanish surnames?
For you to have 1 idea we are talking about 1.
600,000 people out of 1 total of 2.
200.
000 that are the inhabitants of the Canary archipelago and that many of
the people who carry these surnames and that are the most common in the
Canary Islands can quietly think that their origin is Spanish and it is not so.
Professor and paleontologist Francisco García Talavera says
that this influence is not sufficiently known or valued in
Canarian society in general despite the fact that this
influence is manifested in 1 lot of words in culture in general even genetic.
So if they had so much influence,
how could they not leave their surnames as an inheritance?
Obviously many are already writing it in the comments.
The influence I am talking about and that has been so
important in the Canarian culture is the Galician-Portuguese,
the human contingent of Portuguese,
especially from Madrid and,
who arrived in the islands after the conquest by the Crown of Castile of
the Canary archipelago was monumental and did not leave 1 important
volume of surnames more than 1 hundred These surnames of Portuguese origin,
most of them were compulsorily Castilianized.
Canary Islanders because they were transformed,
that is,
they began to be written as they were pronounced.
I suppose you will be eager to know if your last name is
included in this list but I will give you the 10 Most common ones,
the ones that export it more than 3 others that have 1 special mention
and I will do it in another video because if I don't get this one forever.
Well let's get down to business Take note and look closely because I am going
to put it also in writing of which are those 10 surnames that are repeated most
among the population born in the Canary Islands And of course do not stay with
this information If you know someone with these surnames and share by the order
of number of people who carry them in the islands I will choose 1x1 the 10/1
Ramos the first Marrero delgado Acosta Rivero
Méndez Sosa Alfonso Luis and padrón.
These are the 10 surnames that are repeated most among
the Canarian population apart from the 3 I have said that
have 1 special mention and that I will do in another video.
You need 1 of these last names Do you think you have
it Let me know share don't stay with the information.
If you know someone who has 1 of these surnames,
it is very strange that you do not know someone,
send them this video,
you will still get 1 surprise.
And thank you very much from here to the paleontologist professor Francisco
García Talavera for the intense work he has done for decades onomastics in the
Canary Islands and through his work he comes to the conclusion that surnames
represent an extraordinary tool to know the
historical evolution of theed peoples,
in spite,
he says,
of the aculturative attempts of theer.
So again,
all the gratitude for contributing and shedding
light on 1 important part of Canarian culture.